you got in shape before you got sober
yeah I lost a considerable amount before
wow I was a big boy my wife keeps saying
like you don't have to talk about it
that much I'm like the people they love
it hey Vinnie dude does this give you
hope for the future I mean yeah for sure
you guys said that you never see an old
overweight person that hit me so hard
cuz they're like oh you see old people
smoking with their oxygen machines but
you don't really see an overweight old
person and I was like okay I really need
to do something something but it's just
so hard dude I'm at home and I just like
okay I'm hungry I want to eat something
and I'm looking at I'm like I shouldn't
eat that but then I eat it anyway and
then afterwards I feel shame why is it
in the
house because I get it you know like
I cuz I bought it food is awesome food
is the best thing and it's like dude
it's just tough